comment allez-vous aujourd'hui je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un mec j'ai
jamais vu ça
cette histoire c'est un méga bordel et
elle est infini espace toujours des
nouvelles choses plus aux hawks celle
d'avant quand je vous parle de mcafee
vous pensez à ceux très célèbre
antivirus qui casse les couilles
qu'est-ce qu'il est relou genre il
change tout moteur de recherche par
défaut il est hyper intrusif et il est
très dur à désinstaller
à tel point que les équipes ont dû
sortir un logiciel qui sert à le
désinstaller pour de bon du pc
aujourd'hui on va parler de cet
antivirus y aurait pas grand chose de
plus à dire mais on va parler du
créateur de cet antivirus aka john
mcafee c'est un mec qui très honnêtement
avait tout pour mener une longue vie
heureuse est saine et qui s'est dit un
jour si je devenais une horrible
personne là comment l'inventeur d'un des
tout premier antivirus du marché en est
venu à fuir la justice à partir en
cavale pour des suspicions de meurtre à
est accusé d'avoir créé des drogues de
synthèse le tout dans un calme
grandiloquent cette histoire c'est celle
de john mcafee et franchement j'ai
rarement vu ça dans les histoires points
[Musique]
commençons par le début mai où né john
mcafee squeeze est né en angleterre en
1945 son père est américain sa mère est
anglaise et très vite ils retombent
vivent aux états unis en virginie dans
une petite ville qui s'appelle salem et
là pas de chance le père de john est un
grand grand alcoolique et il se suicide
alors que john n'a que 15 ans évidemment
il est profondément impactés et à cause
de ces événements par la suite il
deviendra accro à l'alcool et à de très
nombreux tombe mais pour le moment john
certains adolescents et malgré ces
incidents horrible et tient bon john il
est brillant en maths gens il a une
carrière académique toute tracée devant
lui il obtient une licence et poursuit
un doctorat en mathématiques dans les
années 60 franchement respect il est
encore traumatisé du suicide de son père
mais il tient bon et des studios c'est
vraiment un beau gosse à ce stade
et puis un jour job pendant son doctorat
il a une excellente idée il se dit et si
je faisais sexe avec une des élèves en
licence que je supervise c'est une bonne
idée ça allez hop
l'école est au courant il se fait
dégager c'est chaud et la john
évidemment se remet en question il se
dit pourquoi j'ai fait ça je suis
peut-être allé un peu loin
pas du tout il se marie avec cette
étudiante tout simplement et
professionnellement parlant et devient
programmeurs pour des petites
entreprises comme la nasa
je vous ai dit le gars est chaud après
il devient de plus en plus celle où vous
allez voir mais pour le moment
franchement respect professionnellement
en tout cas cette expérience à la nasa
ça fait de lui un des mecs les plus
chauds dans le milieu de la tech
à cette époque il enchaîne les contrats
juteux auprès différentes boîtes de
secteur et ils continuent de se droguer
souvenez-vous il n'a pas encore réglé ce
problème là mais il se justifie auprès
de sa femme et de sa mère en expliquant
que dans le milieu dans lequel ils
essaient méga courant genre tout le
monde se droguent bombe a aucun problème
alors c'est vrai que c'est tout le monde
le feuillage 0 blême en vrai carton
rouge de la part de sa femme elle est
profondément déçue et elle le quitte
mais peu importe johnny continue d'être
un petit crack dans le milieu de la tête
et au milieu des années 80 il va se
passer un truc qui va l'emmener un tout
autre niveau
il travaille alors pour l'oc id je sais
pas comment on dit ce nom ça sont
séparables ce que ce nom vous dit
probablement rien mais à l'époque c'est
une société énorme qui produit entre
autres plein d'avion des technologies
militaires et ils ont contribué à
l'élaboration du télescope hubble
l'un des plus connus de tous john
travail donc dans ce milieu
impressionnant qu'elle aéronautique et à
nos jours et reçoit entre ses mains un
virus informatique
un virus appelé le brave virus waouh
c'est nouveau à l'époque n'y a pas de
virus existent pas ce brave virus c'est
l'un des tous premiers virus ayant
attaqué les machines ibm de l'époque
en gros ça ralentit c'est complètement
les ordinateurs via le disque est
infecté il faut comprendre que c'est la
première fois qu'un truc de cette
ampleur arriver la notion de virus
informatiques n'existait pas à l'époque
john évidemment il est fasciné et il va
étudier le sujet et décide d'analyser le
brain virus pour comprendre comment il
fonctionne mais en plus de comprendre
comment il fonctionne il va réussir à le
contrer il va développer un antivirus
pour protéger les machines et les
cliniques grâce à cette expérience en
1987 john décide de créer sa propre
entreprise
sobrement intitulé mcafee à sousse yates
la prochaine fois que je lance une
marque je l'appelle hochart rien à
[ __ ] en gros quand il a découvert et
résolu le problème du moins de virus il
a très vite compris que c'était le
premier
série et que tant curé l'informatique y
aurait toujours des gens pour créer des
virus et que lui il aurait donc un
boulevard pour créer des offres de
sécurité informatique auprès du grand
public au moment franchement il est
chaud il a résolu ce truc du brain virus
il est visionnaire il se doute que va y
en avoir plein d'eau qui prépare
l'arrivée de d'antivirus du coup auprès
du grand public franchement c'est beau
ce qui se passe pour le moment là vous
vous dites mais pourquoi il fait cette
vidéo squeeze je comprends pas où il
veut en venir sur john mcafee c'est
normal pour le moment on a énoncé le
succès du gua et ce qui l'a amené à
toucher beaucoup d'argent par la suite
vous allez voir mais on n'a pas trop
parlé du personnage de comment il est
john mcafee ça un perso étrange vraiment
par exemple à l'époque quand il était
interviewé sur ses produits sur son
logiciel antivirus
il disait calmement que lui il l'avait
jamais utilisé était ensuite que pour
lui tout tu sais sur quoi tu cliques
t'as rien à craindre ce qui est quand
même bizarre venant de la part d'un mec
a créé un antivirus qui est censé
protéger son ordinateur fin c'est
bizarre ces discours autre chose sachez
que chez mcafee associatif
l'ambiance au travail à les excellentes
apparemment puisque john eales à des
méthodes de management qui sont
particulières par exemple et distribuer
des bons points aux employés qui
couchent ensemble dans des endroits
insolites du bureau vous avez compris là
pourquoi cette vidéo existent bref en
1994 john à 49 ans et décide de se
casser de son entreprise et va revendre
tout sépare pour la modique somme de 100
millions de dollars est là on pourrait
se dire [ __ ] de bâtard comment il va
kiffer sa retraite petite maison
incroyable petit voyage le kif et ben
non
pendant les dix années suivantes johnny
va pas vraiment profiter de son argent
il va plus passer son temps à essayer de
créer d'autres business parmi lesquels
se trouve un projet de messagerie
sécurisée
donc voici une image qui trônait à
l'époque sur leur site perso je me sens
pas spécialement en sécurité là il va
aussi créer des parfums yves à investir
dans l'immobilier tout cela avant de se
reconvertir dans le yoga owen jones mais
a donné des cours de yoga à écrire des
livres de yoga et ils ouvrent eux mêmes
un institut de yoga d'origine de ces
villas pouvant accueillir jusqu'à 200
participants à ce stade on sait pas trop
si juste il se fait kiffer ou s'il est
un peu en train de briller et vous allez
très vite avoir la réponse
on est en 2008 l'année où il ya eu une
énorme crise financière et john et cela
prend pleine tête
sa fortune estimée à 100 millions de
dollars auraient fondu en 4 millions de
dollars ça fait mal
et là on pourrait se dire que c'est
probablement la fin pour ce mec qui a
été durant des années un génie de la
tech et alors là vont très vite que fait
john est ce que ça y est à 63 ans et
prend pour de bon sa retraite
est-ce qu'ils profitent de l'expérience
de toute une vie dans l'informatique
pour fonder une nouvelle société essayer
d'aller retaper un jackpot ou est-ce qui
plaque tout pour créer un laboratoire
pharmaceutique au milieu d'une jungle
protégé par des gardes armés jusqu'aux
dents
[Musique]
j'avais donc le choix le plus évident et
part s'installer en amérique centrale à
belize officiellement pour faire des
recherches sur la détection du cours
ayant une culture générale
énorme vous le savez je vous explique ce
que c'est en gros il fait de la
recherche sur des antibiotiques parce
que les certaines plantes à belize corps
et des propriétés intéressantes
il rend compte alors sur place une
scientifique qui est spécialisé dans le
domaine docteur ado lizio le deal est ce
un johnny lui finance un laboratoire du
matériel et de la main d'oeuvre et elle
elle mène à bien les recherches
l'ambition des deux étant ni plus ni
moins de révolutionner le monde
pharmaceutique en mettant au point des
herbes médicinales
là on n'est plus trop dans l'anti virus
y on sent qu'il ya un petit tournant qui
a été pris quand même au même moment et
dans les landes ce nouveau départ pour
john il assure avoir arrêté tout ce qui
est lié de près à l'alcool ou la drogue
on est donc sur un tableau assez ouf ou
en pleine jungle sur un terrain qui vaut
à 25 millions de dollars
john a fait construire un énorme
laboratoire dessert dans lequel il ya
des dizaines d'employés est gardé par
une milice armée tout ça pour évidemment
mettre au point des herbes médicinales
ça ressemble à un autre game le game de
l'air médecine alnot rapidement docteur
ado need you elle sent qu'elle s'est un
peu fait berner que tout ça n'allait
reconnaître que du vent puisque ça
ressemble pas trop aux autres
laboratoires de recherche et qu'en plus
de ça je n'ai pas du tout investi et
déjà mais là et du coup rien n'avance
comme prévu sauf que john c'est un peu
une grande gueule du coût des fois il
ramène des journalistes au laboratoire
docteur adonis gohelle à sa réputation
en jeu puisque c'est connu que c'est
elle qui dans ce labo à gérer cette
recherche d'armes et finale sauf qu'elle
avait sur le terrain elle voit bien que
rien avancer que c'est pas trop ça
qu'ils sont en train de faire dans cet
endroit
mais quand des journalistes passent au
labo john a la solution il remplit des
fioles de colorants pour que ça ait
l'air clean et scientifique
et ça passe les journalistes sont
contents les images circulent tout va
bien sauf qu'au même moment sur des
forums spécialisés sur les drogues
oui ça existe non on n'y allait pas un
utilisateur dont le pseudo est stuff
munger et qui dit s'appeler john
explique qu'il essaie de synthétiser du
mpd v du méthylène dioxyde pire ovale et
ron qui et devinez quoi une drogue
hautement psychoactives et poste après
poste johnny lâche un peu plus d'infos
sur lui il explique qui vit au coeur de
l'amérique centrale qu'il a un
laboratoire toutes équipées au milieu de
la jungle et qui cherche absolument
améliorer ses processus de synthèse
ça fait beaucoup là non suite à ça il ya
des journaliste de gizmodo qui sont pas
coup et qu'ils comprennent ce qui se
passe et que le john du forum égale le
john baca fille de la vraie vie du coup
il médiatise leurs découvertes et john
prend la parole pour se justifier et il
explique qu'il est bel et bien
stop hunger sur le forum dassault ne
peut pas faire genre que c'est pas lui a
trop d'infos qui correspondait à lui
mais en revanche il nie totalement le
fait d'avoir un laboratoire clandestin
dans lequel ils essaient d'élaborer des
drogues en pleine jungle et justifie de
manière un peu mal il dit non mais les
gars a par contre quand je disais ça
c'était une blague ya 0 vannes ils dit
vraiment ça et ça passe
bref docteur ado need you très
rapidement elle en a marre là les piéger
elle est dans un environnement qui est
pas du tout le sien dans lequel on lui
demande d'essayer de synthétiser des
drogues alors qu'elle n'a jamais signé
pour ça en plus le mur c'est chelou au
labo elle est entourée de gens armés et
fins bizarre sans compter tous les
autres trucs chelous de john et
magouilles avec les gangs locaux il
invite des gens de l'étranger qui sont
tous armés fin ça craint bref on est
très loin de la promesse que john lui a
fait c'est à dire faire progresser la
science
les choses sont déjà étrangers son mail
de vienne
plus il ya un documentaire qui est sorti
sur john mcafee qui s'appelait gringo
the dangerous life of john mcafee et
dans ce documentaire on y apprend pour
la première fois des choses scandaleuses
un jour à denise you prend son courage à
deux mains et elle va voir john et elle
lui explique qu'elle veut se casser
elle n'apprécie pas du tout son travail
au sein de l'entreprise et son pays mais
manque sa famille lui manque
bref elle veut rentrer aux états unis
lors de cet échange avec john elle
pleure énormément c'est une grande
annonce et c'est un changement dans sa
vie et donc elle a hyper mal au crâne
john lui propose alors un verre de jus
d'orange avec deux comprimés soit des
andes et doliprane et là c'est l'enfer à
donnizaux se réveille et elle se
rappelle de rien tout est flou et de
toute évidence elle comprend que john
l'a droguée et là elle a un flash
elle se souvient de john nu sur elle au
petit matin elle est en pleurs elle en
est malade évidemment elle s'enferme
dans la maison toute la journée elle
réalise ce qui lui est arrivé elle est
complètement choqué le soir à leur
croiser john et john agit comme s'ils
s'étaient jamais arrivé et malgré ça
elle prend son courage à deux mains pour
l'urée expliqué qu'elle se casse et
surtout pour le confronter directement à
ce qu'il s'est passé puisqu'elle a
compris ce qui s'est passé et cette
discussion elle finit par john qui la
pousse qui l'insultent de tous les noms
et qui découlent de john monte dans les
tours monte dans les tours et john est
un mec armée et un peu parano qui plus
est donc docteur ado need you elle est
complètement terrorisée et elle se
réfugie elle se barricade dans le
laboratoire
elle appelle alors ses amis à leur
demande de l'aide à leur dit que c'est
très grave et quelques heures après
seulement elle est de retour aux
etats-unis arrivé aux etats-unis elle
prend directement contact avec le fbi
pour leur expliquer tout ce qui s'est
passé
déjà le fait que john les droguées et
violées ce qui l'a totalement
traumatisée et aussi les vraies
activités de john là bas malheureusement
le fbi à lui expliquent qu'ils peuvent
rien faire parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'autorité nécessaire pour intervenir à
bélis finalement elle est saine et sauve
mais traumatisée et surtout elle ne peut
pas faire payer john pour ces crimes qui
sont extrêmement graves
là on vient de voir le vrai visage de
john il est complètement fêlé
il est extrêmement dangereux et surtout
il dans un endroit où il a beaucoup de
pouvoir puisqu'il est pote avec les
gangs locaux et qu'il est riche en
fibres et donc malgré ces épisodes et
continue tranquillement ses activités au
coeur de belize
mais un jour tout de même
justice la brigade antigang de belize
prend d'assaut sa propriété ils la
prennent d'assaut parce qu'ils
suspectent john d'être une sorte de
barons de la drogue chez lou qui produit
des méthamphétamines il ya quarante
policiers du swat qui se ramènent dans
la maison john et c'est une arrestation
musclée il fracasse la porte et
maintenant tous les employés gardes du
corps et ma note aussi john et la met
directement en garde à vue pour
l'interroger
là on est soulagé on se dit [ __ ] mais
enfin quelqu'un fait quelque chose pour
ce gars qui est vraiment dans
l'illégalité fin ces objets ou ce qu'il
est dangereux et qu'il faut intervenir
là quand même
mais sur le papier tout semble les gars
c'est à dire que même si la police a pu
mettre la main sur des liasses de
billets et des armes dans la villa jones
selon la réglementation à belize rien ne
justifie le fait de le mettre en prison
je serai curieux de lire cette
réglementation john mcafee et donc
relâché et à ce jour entre temps il
aurait déclaré qu'il est persuadé que ce
raid ce jour là était liée au fait qu'il
y avait un homme politique de belize qui
lui demandait deux millions de dollars
qu'il aurait refusé de lui donner
john est donc de nouveau en liberté on
sait à quel point c'est un homme sain et
inoffensif il sort avec une fille de
saison voilà directement et comme toutes
les relations saines et normal il ya des
petites turbulences qui s'installe mais
rien de méchant juste sa meuf a failli
lui met une balle dans la tête
un soir comme il ya des flammes partout
chez john elle jouait avec un gun elle a
pointé vers john elle a tiré et la balle
est passée à quelques centimètres de la
tête de john est ce que ça a posé un
souci à john pas du tout ils sont restés
en coupe les mois qui ont suivi
bref entre le raid et cette petite
dispute de couple john décide de prendre
des vacances
il se réfugie dans sa villa à san pedro
toujours au belize sur place il est
toujours entouré d'une dizaine de femmes
et d'une milice constitué d'environ 20
gardes armés jusqu'aux dents et c'est là
je dois vous parler d'un nouveau
personnage dans cette histoire grégory
folle
grégory folle c'est le voisin de john à
san pedro c'est un ancien propriétaire
de bar aux états unis qui a pris sa
retraite après avoir tout vendu et qui a
décidé de finir sa vie au calme dans sa
maison de vacances
sauf que sur place lui ce qui vaut à
grégory en regardant par la fenêtre
c'est pas un méga reposant c'est un mix
entre playboy énarque hausse il aurait
même vu des trucs très bizarre puisqu'il
aurait vu john de très nombreuses fois
s'allonger sous un mac avec un petit
trou taille au milieu du hamac prévu
pour qu'une prostituée s'y assoient et
fasse ses besoins sur john en fait j'ai
même pas envie de savoir arrêter de me
dit plus sa brève grégory c'est
clairement pas le calme qu'il espérait
il porte plainte officiellement auprès
de la municipalité en expliquant que
c'est invivable être le voisin de john
il explique qu à des taxis qui arrive à
toutes les heures déposé des gens
surtout des filles chez john et que ça
saoule tout le monde il explique que les
chiens de jeunes à bois 24 heures sur 24
et surtout son dangereux qu'ils auraient
attaqué des touristes et par dessus tout
que ses gardes sur armés terrorisent les
habitants de la région tout en s'amusant
régulièrement à les éblouir avec leur
lampe torche
bref honnêtement grégory qui porte
plainte on comprend sauf que
malheureusement ça ne change rien les
semaines et les mois passent grégory est
désespérée et là ils décident d'agir
qu'est ce qui pourrait bien faire selon
vous votre voisin a l'air très dangereux
il a l'air d'être pote avec des gants
ils aident milices armées autour de chez
lui que faire des ménages est non il
empoisonne les chiens de job avec une
tortilla qui plus est gse de taille je
vous l'offre
et quelques jours après grégory folle ce
voisin un peu encombrant un rôle où
grégory est retrouvé mort assassiné
d'une balle de 9 mm avec des traces de
taser sur tout son corps mais le mystère
reste entier qui aurait bien pu vouloir
la mort
messieurs dames de grégory qui l'
enquête commence et officiellement les
policiers n'ont aucune piste sur le
pourquoi du comment
alors évidemment ils veulent toquer chez
les voisins pour prendre leur témoignage
est en tout cas chez john il est pas là
parce que comme toute personne innocente
john a disparu la police continue
d'enquêter malgré tout mais elle veut
vraiment parler à ceux john key et le
voisin direct de grégory et puis
quelques jours plus tard quelque chose
apparaît dans la presse c'est une
interview de john qui explique fièrement
qu'en voyant les policiers s'approcher
de sa maison et s'est enterré dans le
sable est couvert la tête avec un carton
pour pâques les policiers le trouve et
le plus relou c'est que ça a marché
ils n'ont pas trouvé et quand ils sont
barrés les policiers john il a pu
s'enfuir tranquille mais malgré tout
dans cette interview il a quand même une
réputation à tenir et il tient à
justifier de sa fuite
un peu suspecte et donc il affirme que
pour lui grégory n'est pas du tout celui
qui a empoisonné ses chiens il assure
que ok il ya eu pas mal de dispute entre
eux notamment sur la façon correcte
d'utiliser un hamac et justifie la mort
de grégory par le fait encore une fois
que certains politiciens véreux en ont
après lui les assassins ce serait donc
trompé de maison et aurait tué grégory
au lieu de tuer tschopp il explique donc
que sa cavale c'est pas une façon de
fuir la justice
mais c'est surtout une fuite des
autorités qui en ont apparemment après
sa vie c'est pas la meilleure des
défenses je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord mais c'est sa version de
l'histoire et john il adore parler dans
les médias il adore attirer l'attention
et à chaque fois mine de rien il réussi
à laisser le doute quoi sur la réalité
des fêtes ceci dit dans le documentaire
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
gringo on apprend juste après la mort de
ses chiens
jeune il aurait versé 5000 dollars sur
le compte d'un homme de main etc l'un
des agents de sécurité john était chargé
de récupérer le jour du meurtre
la voiture de cet homme de main à
proximité de la maison de grégory et
quand on demande à cet agent de sécurité
à quoi servait l'argent qui a été versé
à l'aube demain il répond tout
simplement que c'était pour tuer grecque
parce que john key était fou de rage
aurait voulu tuer greg fin à partir de
là john est donc officiellement en
cavale
parce que les autorités sont après lui
pour lui poser des questions sur le
meurtre de grégory morte qui aux yeux du
monde
il a l'air d'avoir commis mais pendant
cette cavale john continuent très
régulièrement à donner des interviews a
rencontré les journalistes à être
présent dans les médias il adore cette
attention qu'on lui porte
mais un jour c'est carton rouge pour le
joueur américain un journaliste device
poste une photo sur le web où il est
avec john et cette photo comporte des
coordonnées gps du lieu de l'interview
john serait apparemment au guatemala un
pays à côté du belize il aurait donc
réussi à fuir le belize grâce à des
complices a évité les checkpoint des
policiers puisque c'était vraiment
fugitifs recherchés et par la suite a
continué sa petite vie de vedette auprès
des journaux les autorités locales font
cette fois ci accompagné d' agent
d'interpol en plus de ça et
l'arrestation est filmé par weiss
encore une fois et en direct et là vous
êtes contents vous vous dites ça y est
ce en est enfin finie ce trou du cul et
derrière les barreaux il pourra plus
faire de mal à personne
vous avez un peu raison il est bel et
bien derrière les barreaux dans une
prison du guatemala mais baissent pas
les bras évidemment y réfléchir un plan
d'abord il compte demander l'asile
politique carton rouge c'est refuser fin
du plan malheureusement il va trouver
mieux comme il a 67 ans il va faire
semblant de faire une crise cardiaque
et ça marche moins d'une semaine après
son arrestation john part en direction
des états unis et évite donc d'être
extradé au belize à cause d'un vice de
procédure et ce bâtard il s'en cache pas
et clame très fièrement qu'il a failli
ses soucis de santé son arrêt cardiaque
pour gagner du temps et se barrer fin
il rentre donc tranquillement chez lui
aux états unis et il évite tout souci
lié à cette affaire de meurtre puisque
l' enquête n'a pas pu avancer sans lui
bélie c'est un petit pays ils ont pas
beaucoup de ressources et ils n'ont pas
pu faire tous les tests adn nécessaires
pour faire avancer les enquêtes john
mcafee redevient donc un citoyen
américain l'an
ou du moins pour un certain temps à
cause d'une justice assez lente en 2013
il fait un peu chier john et décide de
mettre un méga attaqué à l'entreprise
qui porte toujours son nom
il sort une vidéo mais lunaire une vidéo
qui s'appelle comment desinstaller
mcafee antivirus une vidéo dans laquelle
il a entouré de plein de meuf très peu
vêtue dans laquelle ils vivent de la
drogue
bref c'est incompréhensible et
apparemment il aurait fait cette vidéo
juste pour se moquer des médias qui
chaque fois qu'il parle de lui le
présente comme un baron de la drogue
un peu chelou sauf que du coup bah c'est
une défense de merde surtout quand tu
est bel et bien un baron de la drogue
seul ou alors c'est quoi la suite
squeeze on en a marre je sais c'est long
et si vous saviez johnny tente des
projets à droite à gauche
à un moment il se prend pour un pro de
la vie privée sur internet il sort une
sorte de vpn fins et tente plein de
trucs il va même jusqu'à se présenter
aux élections présidentielles en 2016 et
en 2020 bon vous en auriez entendu
parler s'il avait été élu c'est pas le
cas mais alors comment ça finit [ __ ]
ça finit sur une nouvelle cabane way en
2019 john repart en cavale cette fois
sur un yacht avec sa famille direction
l'europe est alors pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que les impôts
américains lui réclame plusieurs années
d'impayés et ils n'ont pas eu à mener
une enquête de fou hein pour découvrir
ça c'est juste que john en pleine
interview il aurait déclaré que selon
lui les impôts serait une pratique
illégale et qu'il n'en n'aurait pas payé
depuis huit ans je trouve sa fougue des
humains se croient aussi intouchable
après le temps le gars il a fait toutes
les pires crasses du monde des années
avant il n'a pas été condamné donc c'est
que logiquement il doit vraiment se
sentir intouchable de malades mais et
ben écoutez c'est seulement il ya six
mois fin 2020 que john se fait arrêter
lors de son grand périple en yacht lors
d'un arrêt en espagne à barcelone par
les autorités locales
sur ordre des états unis et là ça rigole
pas l'associer total cette affaire ça
risque de lui coûter très très cher là
c'est le fisc américain qui après lui
bon tu peux but est un mec et faire un
viol au béziers les usa va par contre tu
veux l'argent au fisc inquiète pas en
deux semaines il n'y a pas de souci du
coup au moment où on se parle john il
est en prison à barcelone en attente
d'une possible extradition vers les
états unis et de paix qu'il en prison il
ne ferait plus il a parlé à la presse il
adore la presse en l'a compris elle
explique que la prison à barcelone c'est
une expérience formidable que c'est une
petite star auprès des détenus et que
bien évidemment il ne retournera jamais
aux états unis mais sachez une chose
pour des raisons que j'ignore si vous
voulez des news dow jones est possible
puisqu'il est très actif sur son compte
twitter malgré sa détention
je comprends pas clairement il refuse de
disparaître et il veut par dessus
ou faire parler lui ôtant peau ces
messieurs dames c'est donc la fin de
l'histoire de john qui est exceptionnel
je ne comprends même pas que c'est
possible d'avoir une vie comme ça de
faire tout ça et de rester autant dans
l'impunité sur une si grande période
c'est fou j'espère que ça vous a plu il
y avait beaucoup d'infos à donner
j'essaie de faire un déroulé un peu con
s'il ya encore plus d'infos que ce que
je vous ai données dites vous dans le
fameux documentaire s'ils voulaient le
voir d'ailleurs qui est sorti en 2016
kaki plus du tout 10 produire je le
trouve plus mais je sais qu'il existe et
il vient un peu plus sans précisions sur
certains trucs café john lors de son
séjour dans la jungle n'est ce pas sur
mon pc au moment où je vous parle il ya
mcafee qui est préinstallé j'arrive pas
à le désinstaller ça vous rend ouf de me
dire que c'est ce mec derrière bref
passé une très bonne journée je suis
très content de vous avoir raconté cette
histoire et puis je m'en vais y
travailler sur d'autres visent où les
sauces
[Musique]